[Music]
[Music]
the Robin
Blagh want to get right into the rant
maybe it's because I like iris more than
Babbitt I gave him nothing yesterday by
the way this brewing like controversy of
the different filmers and producers man
this battle is very exciting for me
yesterday I went to a Knicks game I wore
an ugly sweater natty light sweater
because I knew I had courtside seats and
I knew that the sweater would stand out
just moments ago I was on SportsCenter
they were showing a ridiculous highlight
that serendipitously happened near me
and then I you know celebrate I'm sure
we're chopping it in right now
and they made a reference to me which
then got a lot of people follow me to
mention me on social I engaged with them
this my friends is what's called classic
attention arbitrage right understanding
what you need to do not only digitally
or by being in the community ninety
times two cents at a time but also
understanding in real life you know
whether it's your speaking style and
it's not about being provocative or
ridiculous for the sake of being
ridiculous you need to be authentic to
yourself right and so it's not a mohawk
or a big hat it's like I can wear some
sweaters I can do that I'm comfortable
with that so it's not forcing it because
lack of authenticity is the
vulnerability at the macro of this whole
game but it's also understanding the
nuances how it actually works what the
world really trades on what breaks out
that I think we've see a lot of bad
versions of people hacking attention
playing to the worst of our traits and
we've seen that historically in many
different ways in culture and politics
and government and business in a million
different ways but there's a fun way to
do it wearing an ugly sweater courtside
at Madison Square Garden is a fun way to
do it it's a subtle way to do it and
it's a treating way to do it and there's
a lot of micro ways to do it as well so
be thoughtful of not only your online
hacking of attention and the execution
of the creative but also offline
so when you're at conferences like so
many of your going to waste so much
money on buying a booth and a tradeshow
in 2018 at least do something
interesting about it not giving away a
free stress ball chachki or a charger
with your logo on it Rick such a
pleasure thank you so much for having me
no thanks for joining us
yeah I'm really excited to heard a lot
about you I'm sorry we weren't able to
talk about no worries no worries I've
got what I needed
I've got a all I truly need is to
reverse engineer what the audience needs
okay and so I have enough context at
this point between the b2b and b2c
behavior and the regionality and
actually I didn't get that look they're
from all over Europe where were the
companies from okay we do have a few
guests right got it but it's this
predominately means 80 percent us a
little Canada and what would be your
guests at b2b versus b2c by percentage
of the audience
yeah and they're bees when they're be
that they're connecting to food services
retail distribution so we stand
everything from the the growers to the
processors to the logistics and
discriminators to the distributors to
the retailer's I understand so it's
probably pretty even spread spread
across those five I understand they're
so famous fantastic they're all really
excited about hearing about the the full
chain yes we always talk to table
Norfork it's for driving farm to a large
consumer centric consumer centric you
know one of the things that really works
for me in getting in a behind the scenes
here again iris this is strictly because
I like you so much more than babban so
I'm giving you so much here I mean this
logs already done I mean we're done here
I mean you're done I mean you know I
call it a day if you notice this
I don't really prep for I talk a lot
about improv I don't prep it's very
simple I work backwards most people
think about
business and then figure out the
customer I think about the customer and
then figured out the business I already
understand what's happening on the
customer in a b2b and b2c environment so
I spend a hundred percent of my time on
and so then when I come here because of
my history of 25 years of understanding
business and really intuitive kind of
entrepreneurial gifts that I was handed
in DNA wise it came natural to me you
know that's it that's it what was this
three minutes of talk between two people
like I'm gonna go slay completely go
savage on these people's faces one of
the best talks they'll ever see and it
wasn't 40 years of you know it wasn't 40
it wasn't four to ten hours of research
it wasn't making a deck for six hours
editing it in here right now it's
because I bet on my strengths I know
what's going on with the consumer which
it makes me disproportionately more
powerful always the end whoever is
closest to the consumer
Amazon me what the way I community
managed read spend all my time consuming
that right also deploying empathy not
being short terms so I'm not asking for
as much I'm so pro consumer you I'm so
pro you but that gives me the
understanding and the leverage and then
I just deploy because everything else is
the same [ __ ] like this this and as big
as this is right and this right it's all
the same at the end got a reverse
engineer I bring value hey okay welcome
is there any way that you can put that
up in the agency slide in the first like
two three minutes for people that may
want to tweet along at home or anything
of that I know the demo the audience but
still just to give them some context
like maybe the first two minutes and
then switch and then end with awesome by
the way in my continuation here this is
all for iris if you noticed I don't know
if iris caught it I asked for them to
shoot they said we're gonna show you
live in the last 20 minutes will show
your slide my slide has my information
my my URLs my youtube channel my
Facebook I asked for the first two or
three minutes for it to be shown and
then do what they want why did I do that
because it's the same game attention
arbitrage if only three people in that
room and that's supposed to be a
conservative baby boomer audience so I'm
looking at three of the 300 if three of
them look up see my twitter handle
follow me and start tweeting along the
way
even 227 followers right one person from
that one person may follow me or be
intrigued by something that person
that's tweeting along while I speak
quotes during my talk that is why subtly
something that wouldn't normally be
edited into this blog in a world where
I'm trying to show you more of my subtle
nature of my nuances that dollar eighty
strategy I'm trying to challenge myself
especially when I love the person behind
the camera
so if d-roc was you're a band Kyle no I
would not but for iris I'm gonna push it
out here make a much better vlog make
the best vlog ever this is gonna be the
best episode ever you know that's why I
asked for it that little subtle thing of
asking for the first two minutes to have
the slide will lead to one potential
person tweeting my quotes along might
talk to 27 followers which one person
may actually find interesting which will
create them to follow one the
acquisition of one it matters no matter
how many people you have following you
[Applause]
morning very very happy to be here
really enjoyed the opening monologue in
in the context of today's morning I
tweeted just now it's been interesting
over the last 72 hours whether in a Wall
Street Journal interview or a business
meeting now a conference and a lot of
one-on-one meetings I've heard the same
thing about 11 or 12 times and it struck
me finally this last time on stage which
is how many people keep saying the word
or the sentence it's changing its
changing I think anybody here this
morning that hasn't fully quantified how
much has actually changed this has
changed I think there's an unbelievable
disconnect between the framework and
strategy of how we are running our
businesses whether it be to B or B to C
environment on us calibrating is it
changing or has it changed and more
importantly the practicality of the
timing I spend very little time on the
impact of self-driving cars in a micro
in a 24 or 36 month window but I try to
undercut understand and quantify them in
a macro I'm not in the luck business I'm
in the marathon running business and
more importantly I'm in the timing
business I'm so deeply actually consumer
centric that I don't have any other gear
the only thing I ever do is try to
reverse engineer the attention of my end
consumer whether in a b2c or b2b
environment and I try to understand
things like it blows my mind how many
people here feel comfortable because
they have long term contracts and
relationships with some of the biggest
companies in the world without realizing
that those companies themselves are so
disproportionately vulnerable and and I
just you know I play with this right I
play with the fact that 80 billion
dollars is spent on television
commercials on the fortune 500 CPG brand
side yet 94% of them lost market share
because not a human being on earth
watches a television commercial
literally nothing we talk about or way
more importantly literally
thing that controls the attention of our
end consumer existed 13 years ago we
need to take a big step back in this
room and understand what we are talking
about is not social media or snapchat
what we are talking about is the
maturity of the Internet itself what
that means to the human race and
everybody in this room including me is
so disproportionally misunderstanding
how substantial this shift is and what
happens over the course of the next
decade the Internet is the middleman
period it was some guy or gal that owned
13 medallions in taxis in this city
second or third it is the hotel rooms
and the supply and demand of that
world's turn today it is the media
companies across the board Stern right
now and it may be your business next
Walmart's not going to give you the
contract Walmart's gonna have to do it
itself they're gonna be they're gonna
buy dairy farms they're gonna grow the
grain everything gets shrunk and so we
have to take a real step back and
understand that there is only one thing
one there's one thing that will keep you
from being a commodity your brand the
only thing that will keep you away from
being completely commoditized is your
brand can you create an environment
where somebody actually makes an
emotional decision or a subconscious
decision not a practical one because if
you're in the middle and people gonna
make practical decisions there's an
enormous amount of vulnerability in the
system and so look this is real
disruption this isn't haha this is over
the course of the next decade 90 80 70
percent of the biggest companies in
multiple sectors will not only decline
but completely diminish and completely
vanish that is minor leagues compared to
the fundamental human shifts were going
through did anybody see the robot that
went viral on the internet the other day
there's like robot that was doing like
twists and turns how many people just
raise your hands I'm curious did you see
what Elon Musk said about it
which was so there's this rope you have
the finest I don't have a lot of data on
there so you know in the feed you know
in the headline reading society I don't
like to talk about things I don't know
here's what I know
a robot that scared the crap out of me
was in my feet right just doing stuff
that makes LeBron look like me right
Elon Musk decides to take that somebody
more educated in robotics than I am and
said something very clever and I know
enough about how he communicates where
he's like you think this is cute in 24
or 36 model members of timing very
shortly
you won't even be able to see this robot
without technology that it will be so
fast that the human eye can't even see
it everybody in this room needs to
realize that we are about to run an
incredibly fascinating business marathon
and most of you aren't even on the
treadmill yet and let me explain the
treadmill to me is how you spend your
money on marketing and sales thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
the only way you're gonna win this is to
run a marathon when it feels like you
need to run a sprint so the first of
almost there's no right way you don't
look at me and that's the right way to
do it there's only one right way what's
right for you as an actual human being
so first and foremost personal brand a
lot of people try to fix things and make
people what they're not versus going
all-in on what they are you have to go
all-in on who you are
I don't even notice to tell you like
this is the framework I call it a
blueprint you call it principle it's the
punchline it's short term long term it's
the value of patience it's micro
failures macro wins it's just all the
same [ __ ] one of the things that's
interesting is I live much more in print
and principles to me things are very
macro there's there's rules about
patience and the long game and humility
self-awareness lack of romance I'm just
not romantic about anything that
happened yesterday things of that nature
well what that does is it gets very
theoretical and I'm concerned that my
audience is getting the framework but
they are so hungry for the details back
to schooling and things of that nature
and I always say leave that to others
but once in a while I get inspired so so
I said look there's nine Trent there's
nine posts per hashtag every day I want
you to pick 20 hashtags that are
relevant to your business or your
ambitions your nonprofit whatever it may
be right so nine times two cents for
every post go to those posts look at the
posts consume the post and add value to
the conversation you end up leaving a
dollar eighty a day of your two cents
times 90 oh cool it is very practical
right and and that is very rare for me
because I'm just not into that it's not
how I process okay but you see you know
those things do it in your do it in your
own way you can just knock these things
off like this you'll love this record I
apologize this is insane that this is
happening Irish this is how you have to
add it today today
iris came to me she filled me all day
today I'm at a conference I'm making a
joke that I like her the best more than
d-roc and bab and the other people that
fill me and i said because of that I'm
gonna start articulating and this is
maybe in the subconscious I don't even
know we were doing the Q&A show today
theoretically I knew it was coming this
week but it could have been tomorrow I
literally started explaining things they
came to me and they said we're gonna put
up your slide at the end of your talk I
said can you put up the slide for the
first two minutes when I go up there and
then you can show me live on the jump on
the three different screens and then you
can end with my slide is there any way
that you can put that up in the agency
slide in the first like two three
minutes
that's just my normal demeanor but what
I did was I challenged myself back to
what you just asked me to do and I
looked in the camera and I explained to
my audience in real-time why I did that
I asked for the first two or three
minutes for it to be shown and then do
what they wanted why did I do that
because it's the same game attention
arbitrage and it's because the way
Twitter works if there was even one
person in that audience that would see
the slide go up follow me on Twitter or
get to know what my handle was and they
wanted to tweet my quotes while I was
speaking that wouldn't have been able to
be done had the slides come at the end
and that's why I always asked for my
slide to go up in the first two minutes
with my social media handles so that the
audience could become the amplification
of awareness of what I have to say and
so I'm starting to get into a process in
this point in my career where I am
starting to challenge myself to get into
these details and I assume that makes a
lot of sense
[Music]